uns ist jetzt martin vinzens sie sind
landesvorsitzender von der fdp nordrhein
westfalen und auch fraktionsvorsitzender
der partei im landtag wieder ganz knapp
noch reingekommen ist ja auch der größte
landesverband hat glaube ich hier auch
die meisten delegierten wir uns jetzt
gerade gehört dass eigentlich die
sogenannten gemäßigten in der partei
gestern irgendwie untergepflügt worden
sind wurde am gestrigen tag nicht nur
die er am morgen begraben sondern auch
der einfluss der westlichen
landesverbände in der afd ein schöner
morgen erst mal
mache ich nicht gern nicht was sie da
direkt an der stelle wieder sprechen das
sehe ich explizit nicht so also die
af.de nach den letzten wahlergebnissen
befindet sich natürlich in einer krise
das brauchen wir auch nicht schönreden
das ist das keine immanent tödliche aber
zumindest eine wenn man sie nicht
behandeln würde und das hat die
mitgliedschaft natürlich in unruhe
versetzt wird es gab jetzt zwei
möglichkeiten entweder ein neues team
was vielleicht mit einem neuen impulsen
dann auch nach vorn gegangen wäre oder
aber die kontinuität gestern hat man
sich sehr eindeutig für die kontinuität
entschieden und dann ja und das muss man
sagen das ist für einen auf dem
parteitag ja auch ja vielleicht fast ein
bisschen ungewöhnlich hat man ja fast 10
europa in seinem team wünschen ja auch
so unterstützt also fast das gesamte
team was er sich vorgestellt hat also
stromlinienförmig stromlinienförmig will
ich nicht sagen aber eine eine
ungewohnte geschlossenheit ja dann doch
die hier präsentiert wurde nach dem kino
copa eben bei viel unruhe in der
mitgliedschaft damit er vielleicht
schwachen ergebnis gewählt wurde für
vier fällen ist auch nicht das ganz
untypisch dass wir uns knapp drüber
schafft aber vielleicht nicht das werk
sei aber danach hat man ihn mir sofort
im prinzip genau auf das zu geschehen
gespräche und hat ihnen unterstützten
sie sind ja jetzt verantwortlich für die
afg politik in nordrhein westfalen das
hätte sie ja um ein haar die
parlamentarische existenz gekostet
offenbar kommt die afg im westen nicht
gut anders als in thüringen wo sie in
sachsen musiker stärkste partei bei der
bundestagswahl wurde in nrw wer sich
fast rausgeflogen also es ist eigentlich
keine partei nach westlichem geschmack
ist auch das kann ich natürlich nicht
ganz so stehen lassen wir sind als
relativ junge partei immerhin beim
zweiten wahl antritt zum zweiten mal in
den landtag eingezogen das ist ein novum
in der
republik dass eine so junge partei ist
tatsächlich direkt schafft wir sind da
natürlich recht erfolgs verliebt gewesen
ist es trotzdem bauen das auch nicht
schönreden es ist ein warnschuss gewesen
mit 5,4 wir haben es ja sie haben es
gerade schon treffend beschrieben gerade
noch mal in den landtag schafft das
macht aber auch dieses
spannungsverhältnis sie aussieht
beobachten dass er hier seit geraumer
zeit mit uns und verfolge auch immer
tagung dazu das ist schwierig ist
natürlich mit den östlichen
landesverbänden zu erzählen dass diese
politik in teilen vielleicht nicht gut
ankommt wenn man dort kurz davor ist die
stärkste kraft zu werden und da dieses
dieses spannungsverhältnis aus zu
aufzulösen und einen mittelweg zu finden
damit einander klarzukommen er auch in
dieser dualität das ist die aufgabe
dafür den nächsten bundesvorstand jetzt
zwei winter schwierigkeiten haben die
westlichen bedürfnisse hier noch
unterzubringen es ist ja so dass
böcke ja hier als spritzschutz rektor
und steuermann des parteitags agiert er
hat für kein amt kandidiert er ist
voller dynamik hat eine klare strategie
und er möchte eigentlich die partei nach
seinem ebenbild verformen da haben aber
westliche
landesverbände und deren vorstellungen
nicht mehr so sehr viel platz auch in
dieser neuen struktur kommission die da
jetzt gebildet werden soll also jeder
jeder politisch aktive möchte natürlich
in der partei so wirken dass es
vielleicht auch seinen eigenen
persönlichen ansprüchen seiner eigenen
politischen vorstellungen entspricht das
ist ja ganz normal also auch eine partei
wie unsere mittlerweile noch über
als 1000 mitgliedern da gibt es ja sehr
unterschiedlich vorstellung auch die
politik dazu hunderte oder bedrückend
wenn sie sagen er war hier sehr präsent
er ist aus einem sehr kleinen
landesverband also sein den festen griff
hat und mit klaren seine
einsatzmöglichkeiten sind ja eben er
über die bühne er über die präsenz hier
die größere landesverbände bayern baden
württemberg nordrhein westfalen ich bin
heute mit weder mit 100 delegierten
angreifers ein fünftel der stimmen soll
wir könnten unsere stimmengewicht allein
durch unsere präsenz der delegierten
schon zum ausprobieren dafür aber genau
dafür einstellung der insel passiert ja
nicht gehabt kleinen landesverband und
ist hier präsent rwe
stehen wir das navi zusage mit den
meisten delegierten und taucht irgendwo
spielt hier keine rolle und auch das
sehe ich nicht so wir haben zwei sehr
gute kandidatin an den bundesvorstand
entsandt wir haben zum einen an auch das
sagt man uns ja häufig jetzt nicht mehr
nach dass wir die professoren partei
sind wir haben liberalen
wirtschaftsprofessor mit professor hart
weil in den bundesrat entsandt wir haben
den bundesvorsitzenden der jungen
alternative carlo clemens maier
landtagskollegen in den bundesvorstand
ich glaube zwei sehr gute kollegen aus
nordrhein westfalen sind jetzt auch teil
des teams von team ico paarlaufen ist
noch in der letzten frage auf die
inhaltlichen diskussion eingehen es geht
heute auch wieder mal um europa beim
parteitag beim wahlparteitag in dresden
letztes jahr wurde er beschlossen raus
aus der europäischen union raus aus dem
euro sowieso wenn man jetzt mal den
konflikt mit russland ansieht der
wirklich gefährlich ist auch für
westeuropa zeigt sich doch der wert bei
aller kritik an der europäischen union
der wert einer gemeinsamen europäischen
linie eines gemeinsamen europäischen
einer gemeinsamen europäischen idee
wieso wollen sie ausgerechnet diese
schutzgemeinschaft verlassen
effekt keine schutzgemeinschaft ist wenn
sie sich anschauen wie allein die
aktionspakete diskutiert werden dann
gibt es dort keine einstimmige mehrheit
dann sieht man genau da die schwächen
auch der europäischen union in ihrem
aufbau dass es dort eben keine
einstimmige lösung gibt es immer wieder
leute gibt die auch den europäischen die
europäische meinung da untergraben wir
sehen uns jetzt auch in der
verteidigungspolitik es gibt eben nicht
diese europäische artikulierte
außenpolitik und nachdem wir ja im
letzten jahr beschlossen haben aus der
europäischen union auszutreten im herzen
ein wechsel zu vollziehen programmatisch
das mir im übrigen persönlich auch zu
weit ging einer derjenigen die sagen wir
müssen daher reformieren und anders mit
der europäischen union gehen aber wir
haben jetzt genau diesen punkt dexxit
leben gefüllt und wenn sie sich das
anschauen dann ist es ganz im gegenteil
eher so dass wir klar sagen dass wir für
ein europa sind dass wir für viel
was wir den briten auch vorwerfen wir
müssen an der stelle jetzt leider
abbrechen denn der parteitag hat
begonnen soweit martin vincent im
phoenix-interview danke dass ihr dabei